Кольорові, великі, чудернацькі й актуальні.
Деякі складно не помітити, інші органічно вписалися в естетику міста.
Мурали - одна з візитівок Києва.
Їх щодня бачать сотні людей, але сприймає кожен по-своєму.
Останніми роками у Києві з'являється все більше муралів,
а з ними й суперечок - що має бути у спільному, публічному просторі, а що ні.
Проблема в тому, що чіткого й прозорого механізму,
з ким і як погоджувати створення муралів, наразі не існує.
Один з останніх резонансних випадків.
На дореволюційному будинку у центрі столиці почали малювати
персонажів роману Віктора Гюго "Собор Паризької богоматері".
Але роботи зупинили жителі будинку, яким не сподобалося зображення.
Вони навіть викликали поліцію.
Потім до них приєдналися активісти.
Назар - один із мешканців будинку.
Це "діч" повна. По-перше, це історична будівля.
Їй більше ста років. Це корява, рагульна штука.
Я б хотів, щоб її замалювали.
Думки перехожих різняться.
Ну, гарно, так. Неочікувано, навіть не задумувалася.
Це дуже погано. Тому що немає тут ніякого сенсу, немає художньої цінності,
нема живопису, нічого цього немає.
Просто якесь неподобство.
Написи он, дивіться: "рагуль", "не вмієш - не роби".
Це не годиться нікуди.
Це точно щось про любов. Точно про любов, сто відсотків про любов,
тому що такі позиції…
Ну, непогано. Гарно. Гарне плаття, біла сорочка, біла сукня.
Щось про любов і весілля, сто відсотків!
Я вважаю, що це найогидніше, що можна було тут зобразити.
Тому що недоречно. Нащо паплюжити стіну?
Я люблю мурали. Багато дуже гарних муралів у Києві,
тут на райончику. Але я чесно вважаю, що це якась крінжова пошлятина.
Команду, яка створювала мурал, представляє мисткиня Євгенія Фуллен.
Дівчина каже, що будівля, на якій планували стінопис,
розташована неподалік французького посольства.
Тому ідея муралу - подяка Франції за підтримку України.
РДА надали дозвіл, КМДА і департамент містобудування
та архітектури надали дозвіл. Мешканців ми попередили, що ми будемо проводити.
Під час цього самого скандалу, оскільки ми зрозуміли, що попередження було мало,
треба було ще й узгоджувати від "а до я" цей ескіз.
Ми про це з мешканцями розмовляли,
я також перед ними вибачилася, що не почула вашої думки.
Ще одна проблема - будівля виявилася пам'яткою з охоронним статусом.
Тож департамент КМДА з охорони культурної спадщини наказав мисткині
замалювати мурал власним коштом, а свою ідею реалізувати в іншому місці.
Євгенія вирішила створити мурал на будівлі хореографічної школи
на столичному Виноградарі, але й тут Нотрдаму не судилося постати.
Ми почали робити, ми мали дозвіл від балансоутримувача
та районної адміністрації. Наразі ми призупинили роботи
через шквал активістів, які відстоюють цю радянську будівлю.
Проти виступили активісти, які захищають архітектуру радянського модернізму.
Кажуть: будівля - унікальна.
Це підтверджує і художниця Інга Леві.
Ця будівля насправді є цінною, вона є частиною комплексу
забудови Виноградаря, створеним Едуардом Більським,
відомим київським архітектором, який створив визначні будівлі Києва.
Щоб ця будівля виглядала добре, треба про неї дбати.
Не замальовувати плитку, а мити і ремонтувати.
Директорка хореографічної школи
не згодна з такою позицією і обуренням активістів.
Бачите, вона падає, ми її заклеюємо, вона падає, ми її заклеюємо.
Тут саме стіна школи і стіна дому.
Перепади температур, і вона відвалюється. Тут вона тече.
Тут на кожному кроці, з моменту входу в школу, здається,
що хореографія чимось завинила перед знаним архітектором.
Всі дитячі простори прикрашені, всі дитячі простори розмальовані,
і всі дитячі простори сучасні. Тому що діти - це майбутнє.
І якщо діти будуть зубами триматися за плитку 80-х років,
як мені пояснювали люди, які сюди приходили,
що треба дітей привчати до природніх кольорів 80-х років.
Чому вони повинні насолоджуватися темно-коричневим кольором?
Євгенія Фуллен теж не згодна з критикою активістів.
Вони хочуть радянської влади, радянські будівлі
і ненавидять які-небудь українські, європейські цінності.
А Нотр-Дам - це європейські цінності.
А я митець звідки? З України.
То чому вона мене ненавидить? Через те, що я українка, виходить.
Суперечки довкола муралів вилилися в обговорення у Київраді.
Там планують запровадити мораторій на створення нових стінописів,
поки не буде напрацьовано прозору процедуру: як і з ким їх погоджувати.
Як регулювати мурали й чи потрібно це взагалі?
Художниці сестри Фельдман - одні з найбільш відомих в Україні стріт-арт-митців.
Вони напрацювали свій унікальний стиль.
Емоції - насамперед це адреналін. Дуже надихнув Бенксі.
І стиль життя. Це і мистецтво, і спорт, і адреналін - усе разом.
Сестри Фельдман створювали мурали і за кордоном, і в Україні -
тут це були школи, дитячі садки, культурні об'єкти.
Коли це мурал, прямо велика стіна, зазвичай це пропонують.
Не те, що ти йшов-йшов, побачив велику стіну і зробив. Це частіше проєкт.
На думку мисткинь, мурали, на відміну від графіті - те, що варто регулювати.
Ескіз хоча би погодити з усіма.
На рівні ескізу, на цьому етапі, можна у фотошопі у будівлю вставити ескіз
і вже побачити, бо все навколо буде рамою для цієї картини.
І чи підходить рама під цей малюнок - цього може не роблять,
не погоджують ескіз навіть. Тому результат на пів роботи
вже нікому не подобається. Треба врахувати все, що навколо, атмосферу…
- Рослини, архітектура, все це.
- Вайб…
Художниця Інга Леві спостерігає за різними містами.
Це одна з тем її творчості.
Щодо муралів мисткиня наводить приклад Дніпра,
де є домовленість між містом і митцями про те,
якими мають бути стінописи. А також приклад польського Любліна.
У них є філіал Dom Słów, який працює з текстами, поезією.
Вони часто розміщують мурали текстового характеру.
Тобто це дуже стримані графічно зображення.
Для створення муралу запрошується графічна дизайнерка,
яка робила там всі мурали, тобто вони мають спільний стиль.
Вони дуже виважені, зберігають тло оригінальної стіни,
не займають всю площу, тому це виглядає добре.
І вони завжди поважають контекст.
Якщо це текстовий мурал, він розповідає якусь історію цього місця,
якимось чином пов'язаний.
Ключовий момент: вони поважають контекст просторовий і історичний.
Художниця переконана, що погоджувати мурали в Києві
насамперед мають фахівці.
Це має бути обговорення.
Спочатку має бути експертна рада, яка затвердить один чи кілька варіантів,
які вже будуть виноситися на обговорення з громадою або місцевими жителями.
Тобто місцеві жителі не можуть бути залучені на етапі першого відбору.
Бо дійсно смаки у людей різні, і не всі вони мають експертність
в художній, естетичній сфері.
У Києві ж поки обговорюють різні варіанти.
Пропонують в кожному районі зробити дві-три локації,
визначитися: на цьому місці можна малювати мурал.
Він там буде три місяці, півроку, рік.
А потім його технологічно замальовують чи стирають,
миють і малюють інші. Ця теза також обговорюється.
Буде таке чи ні - побачимо, як проголосує Київрада.
Але певний порядок буде створений.
У департаменті охорони культурної спадщини певні, що автори муралів
повинні стежити за належним станом своїх творінь.
Але на думку чиновників, історичні будівлі мають бути недоторканими.
На пам'ятках місцевого чи національного значення
взагалі не має бути дозволено малювати мурали.
Це позиція департаменту, це позиції Консультаційної ради,
і я буду на цьому наполягати.
Художниця Євгенія Фуллен вважає ідею регулювати створення муралів неоднозначною.
З однієї сторони, позитивно, що не треба буде шукати безліч інформації
в інтернеті, які документи потрібні для того, щоб створити мурал.
З іншого боку, негативно, тому що ця нова комісія - це нові схеми для корупції.
І я не дуже вірю в те, що це буде чесне голосування.
На думку сестер Фельдман, проблема значно глобальніша.
Насправді в Україні не лише з муралами проблема.
Балкони роблять всі різні, кому що зручно, утеплюють,
банери, вивіски вішають - ніхто нічого не погоджує.
Тому взагалі не дивно, що мурали теж не погоджують.
Мабуть, ми зараз шукаємо баланс.
Спочатку була повна несвобода, потім повна свобода.
І де знайти цей баланс, коли всім буде приємно…
І то всім ніколи не буде приємно, завжди хтось буде незадоволений.
Художниці кажуть: мистецтво суб'єктивне.
Але чи буде міський простір прийнятний для всіх -
спільна відповідальність і митців, і жителів міста, і мерії.